let's imagine two kinds of childhood the
first broadly is the good kind when
you're upset someone is on hand to
soothe you when you're furious someone
handles you calmly when you need
attention
someone is there for you when you can't
understand someone explains when you're
messy someone resists shaming you when
you fail you're not called a loser
whenever problem you'll get through it
in short you deserve to exist whatever
the value system of the competitive
world out there inside you're a huge
value you are for as long as it takes
the center of one or two kindly grownups
universe then broadly there's the
challenging or plain bad childhood when
you cry they call you spoiled when
you're difficult they say it's
attention-seeking when you don't succeed
they take it personally when you're
messy they're disgusted when you try to
be strong they're threatened when you're
weak and unimpressive they belittle you
in short it's a bit of a pity you're
around and you don't quite deserve to
exist you're a burden and in the end
really at the giant disappointment
the first kind of childhood is just
about the greatest gift anyone can
receive it's at the root of the chance
to form satisfying relationships to
accept on sexuality to have ambition
without perfectionism and to approach
adversity with resilience and likewise
the bad sort of childhood is proper
lasting trouble
it keeps undermining relationships
generates endless problems around sex
saps confidence breeds anxieties
self-hatred
we don't yet know how completely to fix
bad childhoods there a proper pain to
have had but here are one or two things
to try very hard to keep in mind to
everything you can to understand the
craziness inside you be suspicious of
many of your first intuitions and
responses watch out for weird stuff
you're going to try to do to sabotage
your chances of flourishing warn people
around you in a gentle an alarming way
about what you've been through
invite them to feel sorry for you rather
than just condemn you for being
difficult try to get all the insights
you can from books therapy thinking
except that this is a legacy you're
going to be carrying around with you all
your life feel without self-pity a
little bit sorry for yourself
you
you